wow
how are you feeling I feel like claims
like this are way too common now I'm
here
properties
new video Ed Sheeran walking into
federal court today the center was in
good spirits even laughing in the
elevator despite the high stakes at
issue did the 32 year old rip off Marvin
Gaye's let's get it on with his song
Thinking Out Loud here's a quick sample
[Music]
we'll be loving you
till till 17
[Music]
.
import the attorney for The Heirs of the
late Ed Townsend who co-wrote the 1973
Soul classic with gay called this
concert video a Smoking Gun
the singer performed a mashup of
thinking out loud and Let's Get It On
[Music]
[Applause]
sit on
Ed fired back on the stand quote if I'd
done what you're accusing me of doing
I'd be an idiot to stand on stage in
front of 20 000 people and do that
there's only so many notes and very few
chords used in pop music coincidence is
bound to happen if 60 000 songs are
being released every day on Spotify Ed
even got a few laps when he went on to
testify that he had not heard let's get
it on until he saw it in the 1999 Austin
Powers movie
[Music]
all this got us thinking out loud about
another movie wow that was a
one of the best songs I've had in my
life in yesterday Ed plays himself and
begins to doubt his abilities as a
songwriter it definitely my mate and I'm
definitely salieri
lawsuits are not a pleasant experience
and I hope that in the future baseless
claims like this can be avoided this is
the fourth time the singer's been hit
with a copyright claim two of the cases
were settled out of court
after a lawsuit involving shape of you
last year Ed scored a huge legal win a
judge cleared him of wrongdoing and
awarded the singer 1.1 million dollars
to cover his legal fees
and some major drama happened to court
late this afternoon the planet Catherine
Townsend Griffin suffered a medical
emergency she fell unconscious and was
rushed to a nearby hospital Ed who was
expected to take the stand tomorrow
looked concerned as she was carried out
[Music]